et avec nous maître prend un avocat de
la famille laroche mettre jusqu'à
présent vous ne vous étiez jamais
exprimé publiquement or le juge ciment
vous l'avez compris laisse entendre que
bernard laroche est au moins au moins
coupable de l'enlèvement du petit
grégory alors que pensez vous de cette
hypothèse qu'elle semble avoir retenu le
juge puis du fait qu'ils le disent
publiquement
tout d'abord monsieur simon est chargé
d'un dossier qui est très difficile
puisque ce n'est pas le premier
magistrat qui s'en occupe et il était
admis par tous que conformément aux
dispositions du code de procédure pénale
cela se ferait dans la sérénité et dans
le silence je dois constater que
malheureusement c'est pas le cas et
qu'il laisse se développer quand ils ne
la lit montrent pas une véritable
campagne contre mes clients la famille
laroche bernard laroche qui meurt sa
veuve marie ange qui a deux orphelins
élevé muriel bolle qui a aussi un enfant
élevé ceci est absolument contraire à
toutes les règles légales et pose le
problème de savoir si on peut
aujourd'hui faire confiance aux juges
simon pour mener cette enquête la
réponse de mes clients et non qu'est ce
que vous comptez faire très concrètement
alors vous allez vers le dessaisissement
du dossier qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire je vous rappelle que d'abord nous
ne sommes ni inculpés ni partie civile
dans ce dossier
bernard laroche était assassiné c'est
une façon de le faire sortir du dossier
c'est la solution villemin est légitime
défense par antithèse puisque cette
organisation on a pris la responsabilité
lorsqu'ils concernent la la famille de
la roche s'est constituée partie civile
on lui dit vous n'avez rien à voir dans
cette affaire
dans ces conditions nous devons tenir
compte comme monsieur simon mélange
l'assassinât de jean marie kuhn main sur
la personne de bernard laroche et l'
enquête en cours et nous demandons que
compte tenu de cela monsieur simon soit
dessaisi m d'après vous at on était un
peu vite ces derniers temps en disant
que christine villemin pourrait être
innocenté dans les prochaines semaines
je ne sais pas comment monsieur garot
mon confrère m caro en temps des femmes
christine villemin sauf qu'il ya dans la
presse et je remarque
avait même publié un livre qui a été
qui a fait l'objet de condamnations qui
a fait l'objet d'une condamnation vira
définitive à part des tribunaux dans
lesquelles on se défend nerfs disant
c'est pas moi parce que c'est la roche
c'est une c'est une attitude un peu trop
facile et qui a été qui a donné lieu à
condamnation m prend est ce vrai que
votre cliente marie ange laroche je
refuse de rencontrer le juge et utilise
pour cela toutes les artifices de la
procédure c'est un témoin capital madame
laroche d'un s'est rendu aux
provocations de monsieur simon avant
qu'il n'y ait ces débordements
médiatiques contenu de son interview du
12 septembre et compte tenu de sa décla
de l'interview qui vient d'accorder au
nouveau détective elle fait connaître
qu'elle ne répondrait pas aux
convocations de monsieur simon qui n'a
plus aujourd'hui la crédibilité d'un
magistrat impartial m est ce que tout
simplement le juge simon n'est pas en
train de redécouvrir ce qu avait
découvert les gendarmes il ya cinq ans à
savoir que peut-être effectivement la
culpabilité se situe plutôt du côté la
hanche
la culpabilité de la roche d'abord et je
vous rappelle que le non lieu qu'elles
verront de monsieur lambert n'a pas pu
être parce que la rumeur aucune
information à charge ou à décharge ne
peut avoir lieu aujourd'hui sur la roche
on ne peut pas juger ben
bien mettre je vous remercie de votre
témoignage et puis je viens d'apprendre
souci une réaction officielle des
autorités judiciaires est attendue cet
après midi à dijon après précisément
interview du président simon qui est
chargé du dossier